a few weeks ago my house in south africa
burned down
oh my god
oh my god
i didn't put it on social media at the
time because i wanted to make it
abundantly clear with this video that
i'm not asking for any help financially
or in any other way my wife gaby and i
are safe and we were able to retrieve
all the non-replaceable stuff the
meaningful stuff as well as insurance
thank god are paying for all the damages
however this meant that we didn't have a
home anymore this fire pushed me to
finally step outside of my comfort zone
and move to los angeles to start my
career as a film director directing
movies for big studios longer form
feature films and this opportunity has
been on the cards for the last two years
now but it took this fire to make me
realize that it's finally time to move
on so in the end it's somewhat
serendipitous
i just realized when watching this edit
back that i didn't explain what caused
the fire so i thought i'd just add this
in here it was due to an electrical
fault in the ceiling caused by
load-shedding outages in south africa
and thank you to my incredible sponsors
that make this all possible this video
was brought to you by fx home which has
an amazing new editing software called
hitfilm that i actually edited this
entire video on i'm currently shopping
around for new editing software as my
current one sucks that being premiere
pro anyways so yeah ethics home i'll
tell you more about it later after the
fire we packed up what was left and
jumped on a plane to the states as we
touched down in hale i had to jump on
another plane to berkeley san francisco
to meet with the warner brothers
discovery team how are you
this is tom
until today we had never met in person
before but have made more than 20 films
together over the last three years
while cruising through san francisco i
thought i know this place these super
steep hills remind me of something which
is my all-time favorite piece of content
an ad from 18 years ago where they threw
thousands of bouncy balls down a hill
for sony this is what inspired me nearly
two decades ago to become a film
director
i had to find the street
[Music]
i think it's done there levinsworth it's
not the street even though all the roads
look the same after some digging and a
lot of hope from tom tower
we found it
this makes me so happy
now all i had to do was get a [ __ ] ton
of balls
[Music]
what is that
no they're gonna bounce down the hill
dude
and then more importantly we're gonna
need to recruit someone to try and help
me find my balls
it's so stupid so that means we're going
to need some sort of like a net or
something like that successful mission
see you at 4 00 a.m
[Music]
okay mr foy am wake up it's now
9 13 and i have to be on a flight at 10
30
and before that we still have to throw
all these balls down the hill
so
yeah but on a positive note we found
someone willing to pick up all the balls
this is ollie okay so here's the plan we
got a boot full of balls
we've got a ball catcher
we've got a ball wrangler and safety
officer to make sure that nobody gets in
the way of the road down here i'm going
to drop the balls so they're going to go
right down there
okay but we got all the safety things
the balls can't hurt anyone
see doesn't hurt not one bit
a bunch of these balls bouncing down
that hill me being able to watch it
is
a dream come true let's do this
[Music]
standing here watching colorful balls
bounce down this exact hill where my
initial passion stemmed from was pretty
emotional for me i'm not gonna lie just
thinking of the last 18 years and where
filmmaking has taken
i did it
i did it
i know it may seem silly but to me it's
an incredible feeling what a moment
my balls weren't nearly as bouncy but
they were a hell of a lot bigger
so
that's the one
[Music]
dan
dan
dan
before moving on and showing you what
else i've been up to in ale a quick
question
how was that edit pretty smooth eh and
it was actually really quick and easy to
use i'm talking about fx homes head fill
the platform that i used to edit this
video so what is fx home fx home by
artlist is a provider of video and image
editing software for anyone who wants to
create videos get started with simple
built-in tutorials learn the basics of
video and vfx editing and start creating
amazing content right now all of the
tools you need to create your first
video with integrated free music and
sound effects and a selection of
ready-to-use customizable template
designs and without those pesky
watermarks you can choose a subscription
tier that fits your creative needs like
the creator plan which only goes for six
dollars and twenty five cents per month
or seventy five dollars bold annually or
you can get the pro plan which includes
a bunch more and only goes for 9.99
or
119.88 build annually so yeah if you
want to better your filmmaking and
become a greater storyteller click on
the link in my description to find out
more and join today i then headed to
laguna beach to go and meet up with
austin keane what's up
good to see you man yes dude good to see
you who is the world champion skim
boarder to learn how to wake surf
i was still super jet-lagged and fell
asleep while doing so
unreal man
yeah so that's it for my first week in
la subscribe and turn your notifications
bell on to make sure that you don't miss
any future videos like next week's video
where i learn how to drive like baby
driver with formula one world champion
jensen patton so yeah comment below
letting me know your thoughts on this
video and other than that don't forget
you're awesome bruh and i'll see you
next week
[Music]
you